est-ce que bientôt tu accepterais
de me céder ta place pour la
présentation du 6 alors tu veux la
vérité oui non
alors pour différentes raisons la
l'essentiel c'est l'oseille voilà voilà
si ça s'améliore peut-être dans le mais
pour l'instant non ma réponse est donc
je ne garde pas espoir et ben totalement
est-ce que je peux poser une question
dans le sens de gens Pascal alors à qui
voulez-vous la poser alors il y a
d'autres personnes sur ce plateau je
répète d'accord une chaîne de télévision
historique comme TF1 vous propose bien
sûr et l'animation d'un nouveau format
télévision
est-ce que vous quittez TPMP avec cet
homme donc vous la question je vais la
traduire si il relance Secret Story et
qui me demandait de revenir le présenter
c'est ça les conditions financières
acceptées tu le mets dans la merde la
réponse est non
ce que vous avez peur que ça se recondue
pas de mensonges
la vérité j'ai quitté TF1 j'ai quitté
TF1 en 2015 ou je ne voulais plus faire
Secret Story c'est pas pour revenir
après ou six ans ou 7 ans après pour
refaire le même jeu et je continue à
dire que Secret Story s'il le refont sur
une chaîne hertzienne c'est-à-dire avec
les les les contraintes notamment de
l'arcom ça n'a aucun sens il faut le
refaire sur une sur une plateforme pour
être libéré des secrets il y avait
beaucoup plus loin c'est pour faire un
truc inodore incolore et sans saveur ça
n'a aucun intérêt comme TF1 mon époque
j'y allais en bourse bouche en le nez
c'est pas la peine qui se bouge de folle
nez voilà je vais la rendre service
voilà une question non c'est très bien
merci Amélie alors moi j'ai une question
pour Gilles
il faut être honnête Gilles chaque soir
tu es à contre-courant dans TPMP tu fais
un peu le buzz malgré toi ou non est-ce
que tu te considères comme la star du
programme la star
alors là la réponse est non
pas du tout
pour moi la seule star de l'émission
c'est Cyril franchement et
[Applaudissements]
honnêtement
essentiel à les plus grand collectif
vous êtes un pilier
non je ne suis qu'un maillon du
collectif non j'ai toujours bossé comme
ça vous le savez bien on est d'accord
sans jamais été mais tu sais que quand
tu n'es pas là tu manques à l'émission
il manque quelque chose
non mais c'est très gentil mais personne
non je crois pas non non tout le monde
peut être remplacé du jour au lendemain
tout le monde est remplaçable sauf Cyril
[Applaudissements]
il passe un bon vendredi soir
alors oui une petite question une autre
question une autre question
justement à mon à mon copain Maxime qui
est à côté de moi suis un excellent
chroniqueur de 6 à 7 et donc du coup tu
vois des présentateurs comme Benjamin
Valérie Bernard ou moi quel est ton
préféré franchement
je vais jouer le cœur je vais jouer la
spontanéité évidemment Delphine tu es
excellent
c'est Simon Jack cocu
[Rires]
j'adore travailler avec vous mais c'est
vrai qu'on ne comprend plus rien de ce
que vous dites est-ce que vous avez
réellement songé oui ou non à vous
rééduquer chez un orthophoniste ou à
utiliser un autre méthode et qu'en fait
c'est plus possible en fait ça se passe
plutôt bien
cette place là je m'exprime c'est ça et
à cette place là je déprime
mais oui donc c'est pour ça mais pour
quel est je ne sais pas c'est c'est pas
c'est d'être c'est pas il y a un truc là
je vais être honnête je dis si par là je
comprends pas ça ne passe pas c'est vrai
vous êtes à peu près au début je vous
remercie je vous remercie je vous
remercie déjà votre question bah oui
bravo super merci
mamie madame moi c'est pas Dieu c'est
pas du tout média parce que je m'en fous
un peu Amélie quand tu vois que tu en es
à peu près au même niveau que moi côté
vie sentimentale est-ce que ça te fout
pas un peu les boules
bonne question
Daniel c'est vrai que quand cyril a dit
que j'étais célibataire et qui me
connaît depuis 20 ans et qui me connaît
célibataire de nombreuses années c'est
vrai que je me j'ai une projection en
plus et toi j'ai l'impression que voilà
c'était moi dans quelques années est-ce
que ça me fait peur
[Applaudissements]
le désert de Gobi votre vie sentimentale
c'est vraiment le désert c'est vraiment
j'ai une histoire avec le père de mon
fils qui a duré de assez longtemps et
depuis qu'on est séparé c'est vrai que
franchement je ne kiffe personne Benji
le truc même pas rien bisous regarde vos
vidéos à l'adresse que ça fiche
et comme quoi et Daniel comme quoi
l'espoir est permis ou le désespoir
c'est une question pour vous aussi
la fin du monde arrivait demain est-ce
que vous accepteriez de passer la
dernière nuit avec moi
la pauvre la pauvre c'est ce qui vous
différencie de Cyril il aurait dit oui
mais non parce que Cyril aurait menti la
vérité voilà expliquez-moi c'est la
différence
[Applaudissements]